[Musique]
l'équipe
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat est aujourd'hui notre invité
pour revenir sur toute cette semaine et
le député alexis corbière bonjour et
c'est brigitte qui va vous présenter
bonjour alexis corbière vous êtes député
la france insoumise de seine saint denis
depuis 2010 est vous avez été 13 ans
adjoint à la mairie du 12e
arrondissement de paris alors votre
parcours est ancré à gauche plutôt à la
gauche de la gauche trotskiste en danse
lambertiste membres de la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire vous faites
le choix du ps
ensuite jusqu'en 2008 puis le parti de
gauche et enfin et les filles vous êtes
un proche de jean luc mélenchon dont
vous devenez le porte-parole pour la
présidentielle de 2017 alors est ce que
vous êtes prêt à rempiler en 2022
puisqu'il est à nouveau candidat le
soutenir évidemment et c'est une belle
campagne qui commence qui commence bien
d'ailleurs pour jean luc mélenchon
la chance qu'on a dans cette campagne
moi qui suis comme vous dites un vieux
compagnon de jean luc mélenchon ça va
faire 25 ans que je suis à ses côtés
c'est que l'ona dans cette campagne
nombre de visages qui incarne la france
en soumises je pense bon il ya eu adrien
cattin s'il ya eu matile panneaux il ya
eu beau faire bouger pas tous les citer
et c'est bon ça fait forcément vous pour
le porte parolat
mais on a remporté par olam multiples ce
que je veux dire c'est que la dernière
fois en 2017
gd le porte parole il est évident que
cette fois ci tous ces visages
une fois j'avais fait le calcul on a dix
neuf personnalités insoumise qui vont
régulièrement dans les médias sociaux
qu'il faut passer un peu la place aux
jeunes mais il y en aura plusieurs oui
plus par ailleurs place aux jeunes ça
c'est une évidence mais j'ai je sais que
je n'ai pas l'air mais j'ai 52 ans
non mais plus sérieusement il ya des
jeunes gens de 28 29 30 en plein de
talent mais moi attendez je vais être au
premier rang de cette bagarre parmi les
porte paroles mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce qui a de très positif c'est
que la parole elle sera multiple et puis
autant jean luc reste une constante et
notre programme autant c'est bien
montrer qu'ils aient tous ces visages là
et puis surtout ce que je souhaite
dans cette campagne séclier des forces
nouvelles qui viennent s'agréger vous
allez être surpris sans doute c'est
juste dans les mois qui
parallèle entre vge qui vient de partir
et emmanuel macron et après vge ça a été
la gauche justement mais une gauche unie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez faire
cette unité autour de jean luc mélenchon
a l'impression que vous êtes parti un
peu en faisant cavalier seul au
contraire non mais il faut commencer
pour agréger d'abord c'est pas une
coquetterie je veux dire l'unité se fera
sur le mot sur le programme et résister
quand même temps restant non mais
l'unité ne peut se faire on peut de
rassembler que sur un programme et des
idées
les jean-luc longchamp est parti tôt
parce qu'il continue à incarner un
programme qu'il a déjà présente en 2017
et disons le clairement qu'il avait déjà
présentée aussi un peu en 2012
il faut aujourd'hui plus de démocratie
avec une sixième république il faut une
transition écologique il faut une
politique sociale fait vous connaissez
les thèmes donc il n'y a rien de
surprenant et y compris après avoir une
pression s'est dit que ce classicisme
cette cohérence était bienvenue dans une
période de trouble alors pourquoi pas
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
dit que notre programme nous étions
prêts à en discuter
on est prêt à discuter de tout avec ceux
qui le veulent ce que nous sommes en
train de faire avec les communistes avec
pourquoi pas des le mouvement génération
avec des socialistes on va d'ailleurs
même s'adresser à eux fait les
socialistes qui nous jette pas des
cailloux comme certains le flanc fait
dernièrement
vous savez les mêmes qui nous parle
unités sont souvent ceux qui sont le
moins favorable à l'unité les unitaires
d'ailleurs sont assez divisés d'apt
c'est l'unité mais derrière jean-luc
mélenchon drogba pas nécessairement
enfin je veux dire moi je pense qu'il
est le mieux apporter programme mais
nombre de gens que je vois aujourd'hui
être des candidats un peu apparaître
notamment avec l'aide de certains jours
je pense notamment à madame hidalgo
le poème dany dalle gauche je vais pas
là la critique et à titre personnel mais
quel est le programme être candidat ou
candidate pourquoi pas mais pour faire
quoi
escale singulier c'est que des gens sont
prêts à faire le paraguay doit être
candidat mais ils n'ont pas de programme
je dis aux français méfiez vous des gens
qui veulent bien d'être candidat mais
qui n'ont pas mélenchon
candidat pour la loi s'intéresse à
l'actualité de la semaine on y voit
cea-leti de cette émission le projet de
l'oat confortant les principes de la
république présenté cette semaine en
conseil des ministres il vise à
combattre l'islam radical
le rapport accablant du sénat sur la
gestion de lakovic 19
les sénateurs critique l'impréparation
du gouvernement et point que la
responsabilité du directeur général de
la santé dans le fiasco des masques
la réforme de l'ordonnancé de 45 au menu
de l'assemblée le texte prévoit
d'accélérer les audiences et les
jugements pour les mineurs délinquants
et on commence cette émission avec la
présentation du projet de loi
séparatisme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adopter cette semaine en conseil des
ministres le projet de loi comportant
les principes de la république sera
débattu à l'assemblée à partir du mois
de janvier il vise à lutter contre
l'islam radical en encadrant notamment
la formation et l'organisation du culte
musulman en france le détail avec l
amont à gaza
liberté égalité fraternité mais aussi
éducation et laïcité
voici les fondements intangible de notre
république d'après le projet de loi
depuis plusieurs années ces principes
font l'objet d' attaques répétées
insidieuse de plus en plus nombreuses
qui affaiblissent notre capacité à vivre
sereinement les uns avec les autres
comme l'a indiqué le président de la
république lors de son discours prononcé
aux mureaux le 2 octobre dernier
il est important de nommer les choses le
travail de sape que je viens de décrire
et bien souvent le fait d'une idéologie
pernicieuse portant le nomme d'islamisme
radical 51 article donc dont deux
directement inspirée par l'assassinât du
professeur samuel pet
l'article 18 il crée un délit de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui se délient
punira le fait de révéler de diffuser de
transmettre des informations relatives à
la vie privée familiale professionnelle
d'une personne permettant de
l'identifier de la localiser dans le but
et c'est extrêmement important de
l'exposé elle où les membres de sa
famille à un risque immédiat d'atteinte
à la vie ou à l'intégrité physique ou
psychique
l'article 4 condamne nuit les menaces
violences ou actes d'intimidation contre
les agents du service public
autre axe du projet de loi l'encadrement
des associations elles devront signer un
contrat d'engagement républicains pour
obtenir une subvention en cas de
manquement elles devront la rembourser
en plus des motifs déjà en vigueur une
association pourrait être dissoute si
elle provoque des agissements violents
concernant l'instruction à domicile on
passe d'un régime de déclaration à un
régime d'autorisation préalable
bhl dans certains cas bien précis alexis
corbière sur le principe
est-ce que selon vous la lutte contre
l'islam radical doit être la priorité de
l'exécutif
il faut il doit être mené mais disons le
clairement c'est à la police et aux
renseignements de le faire qu on mélange
tout c'est pas la laïcité qui lutte
contre le terrorisme donc c'est un texte
qui ne sert à rien alors ce texte il
sert à participer me semble-t-il aussi à
une ambiance médiatique entretenue par
le gouvernement pour faire croire
d'abord qu'ils agissent donc je dis aux
français premièrement ne croyait pas un
mot sur le fait que ce texte va aider du
mieux à lutter contre les attentats
terroristes vous avez peut-être lu
d'ailleurs et de l'avocate de la famille
pattison et ému il ya un rapport dudit
passion d'assurer qu a été rendu que
l'avocat de la famille de sa mère pattie
considère comme accablant c'est eux les
responsables je trouve qu'il manque un
peu de pudeur le premier ministre et le
ministre de la justice ministre de
l'intérieur qu'est ce qu'on nous dit
qu'actuellement le système pharos qui
peut déjà repéré sur internet les appels
à la haine qui sont d'ores et déjà
interdits parce que là il enfonce des
portes ouvertes c'est dans ces interdits
y avait que 28 personnes pour surveiller
ça ils ont alerté la proviseure a alerté
alerte niveau 3 en disant que le
professeur était rajhi à tel point
qu'elle lui elle lui a dit attendez
qu'elle lui a demandé de venir avec sa
voiture le plus venir à pied là dedans
une protection qui n'a pas été obtenu
les renseignements ont considéré qu'un
venue de monsieur ses fruits la rentrée
d'un thalys on était parti rend
dangereux donc des fiancés rien sacem
dans le renseignement
donc il faut renforcer pharos le
ministre darmanin va mettre cinq
personnes de plus tant mieux nous ne
cessons de le demander nous cessons dire
qu'il faut renforcer le camp saignement
il faut dix mille policiers en plus
qu'il faut des policiers comme mounir
l'index inutile en tout cas pour le non
mais alors voyager moins d'agitation a
tué renforcer modifié justement après
l'assassinât même bâti à welkom été
suivi dans les articles 18 mais j'suis
pardon mais s'est déjà mise en danger
d'autrui pas d'ores et déjà c'est
interdit chez les français savent que
d'ores et déjà si je vous insulte sur
internet et que j'appelle à la haine
contre vous d'ores et déjà je suis sans
que sanctionner la sa condition en
négation d'information et de la vie
privée
c'est au décès c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle si quelqu'un dit corps bien là
et à telle adresse il faut aller casser
la figure je suis en droit de saisir la
justice sauf qu'il faut des gens qui
repèrent ça actuellement le système est
sous-équipée le système phare aux qui
existe le problème et c'est le cas de
tous ce texte qui a des portes ouvertes
enfoncées sur des sujets qui sont d'ores
et déjà interdits et quand on est moins
chez fait 22
audition parce que j'ai travaillé ce
texte les gens de terrain vous disent
que le problème c'est interdit mais il
n'ya pas parfois des fonctionnaires pour
vraiment aider à accompagner dans nos
statuts des associations pour qu'une
alors sur toutes les actions d'être
alité des simples en dire deux mots sur
les écoles la réalité services publics
la neutralité du service public
il le sait d'ores et déjà exigé d'accord
il ya des jurisprudences qui m'ont donc
pipeau la hausse il n'y a rien de
nouveau c'est que délégataire de service
public
il ya déjà la jurisprudence non mais
c'est franchement je vous assure il n'y
a rien de nouveau c'est interdit elle va
permettre de mieux contrôler
l'organisation du que je me demande si
on a bien vu des problèmes chez vous en
seine-saint-denis la mosquée fermée à
stains à clichy-sous-bois la mosquée de
pantin pantin fermé moins six mois
est ce que ce texte là peut réguler
l'organisation du culte musulman et
vaincre l'islamisme attendait de
l'organisation le culte musulman c'est
pas l'islamisme c'est des sujets
complètement différents d'accord ceux
qui font des actes terroristes non mais
non mais non j'ai juste assure que quand
vous discutez avec des spécialistes du
terrorisme et ceux qui ont suivi ceux
qui ont fait des attentats ce ne sont
pas des gens qui fréquentent des
mosquées a été c'est bien souvent une
des gens qui ne s'y reconnaissent pas
dans les mosquées est tel que l'islam se
pratique et qui veulent autre chose
d'accord donc ne mélangeons pas le cas
de la personne qui a assassiné sa mère
pattie il ne fréquentait pas une mosquée
le ce jeune tchétchène franchement il
fréquentait pas c'est pas c'est pas un
fidèle normal ou est ce que je veux dire
c'était quelqu'un ans mais ne mélangeons
pas tout la mosquée de pantin quand même
quel est le père de william des liens
qui sont établis non mais attendez il ya
une dimension d'emballement sur les
réseaux sociaux sur la mosquée de pantin
ce que vous évoquez c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure si le système
pharos qui d'ores et déjà existent avec
des moyens de fonctionner alors on
aurait pu repérer les choses le y
compris le jeune tchétchène ya eu
plusieurs
ça a été plusieurs fois signifié qu'ils
kid et evian le problème je répète c'est
il ya des dispositifs qui existent et 5e
en train de dire les dispositifs qui
existent donnons leur les moyens d'être
efficace ne faisons pas croire aux
français qu'il faut chaque fois
réinventer l'eau chaude dans le jeu pont
par exemple je vais parmi les thèmes
faut mettre fin au mariage forcé mais
c'est d'ores et déjà interdit de mariage
sur scène
d'accord au certificat d'hérédité faut
mettre fin au certificat de virginité
mais on peut avoir une étude d'impact de
combien de coco qu'est ce que ça
représente
parce que bien sûr que c'est de mon
point de vue une monstruosité mais quand
vous discutez avec les praticiens
il n'y a quasiment pas de demande
vraiment vous avez moi j'ai ce que j'ai
un planning familial qui me dit que dans
le nord sur plus de 4 à 5000 femmes vue
ils ont eu que deux ou trois demandes et
qui ne sont pas en plus majoritairement
des gens de confession musulmane
d'accord parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres confessions qui demande se fait
qu'ils sont amenés parfois certaines
femmes à le demander bref et bien
souvent non mais c'est important ce que
ce que ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on a là une ambiance qui est créée
comme sur la polygamie ont bien moi vous
dire que vous légiférer sur la polygamie
ja forman amichia pas que cet objet
interdit la polygamie donc vous voyez on
crée des choses
cette formation est accusé d' islamo
gauchiste la marche contre l'islam au
togo parce qu'il ya des indigènes et ce
qu'ils peuvent être dans vos rangs
n'importe quoi non mais je vous dis tout
ça c'est n'importe quoi d'accord ce que
vous non mais par exemple est ce que
vous savez ce que gérald harlin
le ministre de l'intérieur et le
ministre de l'intérieur à tourcoing
quand il était député a fait un meeting
avec le ccf ce depuis d'accord d'accord
escaut darmanin est un islamo gauchiste
là comment j'ai jamais fait de meetings
avec le ccf
d'accord lui l'anafé bernard cazeneuve
quand il était ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste a reçu le cci est juste et
maria donc alors ce que je veux dire
c'est que vous avez ce que j'en ai les
six mois terminés
vous avez actuellement quelque chose de
malsain la part du gouvernement qui vise
la france est soumise en une chose une
attaque allusive islamo-gauchiste qu'est
ce que ça veut dire je ne sais pas il
d'ailleurs il ne cherche pas à
m'expliquer aabiza bidco à plaisance
avec moi je suis complaisant avec
l'islamisme vous imaginez vous imaginez
l'ampleur de ce que vous êtes en train
de dire de ce qu'ils me disent je serai
moins complaisant et chris la miss mme e
e qui par ailleurs ce gouvernement
français actuellement qui vend des armes
à des régimes islamistes a dédié à des
monarchies qui fois de ses opposants de
les hisser du moins c'est moi ce que je
dis c'est que s'ils veulent savoir d'un
point de vue géopolitique qui c'est qui
participe à renforcer des régimes qui
d'ailleurs cherche à développer un soft
power d' influence l'arabie saoudite le
qatar en france et face auquel il ne
voit rien à redire mais je reviens à mon
sujet j'aimerais terminer sur le fait
que premièrement je pense et on va avoir
le débat est il ça va être passionnant
j'en suis sûr dans une commission
spéciale qui aura lieu et j'y
participerai pour le groupe france
insoumis sur ce texte et contrairement
aux apparences
j'affirme que ce texte n'est pas intègre
de renforcement de la lettre de laïcité
mais même d'affaiblissement de la
laïcité
par exemple il annonce ce texte et je
m'expliquerai dont la lors du débat
quelque chose qui va permettre aux
églises avec un e majuscule aînés salle
afin de bénéficier de biens de rapports
ce qui était interdit parle en 1905
c'est à dire des bâtiments qui jusqu
alors aucune église hérité d'un bâtiment
elle devait le revendre
elle ne pouvait pas bénéficier chaque
année de ce que lui rapporte ce bâtiment
est bien désormais ce sera possible
et bien moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec
le fait que les églises et plus d'argent
par des activités commerciales
ça va à l'encontre de la loi de 1905 oui
parce qu'en 1905 disait que c'est les
fidèles qui finance le culte c'est
important cette affaire parce que ça
permettait en 1905 il y avait eu un
débat ce qu'il n'y ait pas vous savez
une attitude de la part de certaines
églises qui sur le lit de mort vont voir
les fidèles et essaie d'obtenir 2 qui
ils fassent héritage à l'église donc je
trouve qu'il ya un paradoxe à ceux qui
veulent renforcer la laïcité en vérité
vont donner plus d'argent aux églises et
autres arguments parce que c'est le
président la fédération protestante de
france qui le dis c'est que ce texte si
mr la manière danse organise les cultes
alors que ce n'est pas l'esprit de 1905
qui tenir une conception libérale des
religions qui s'organise comme elle veut
l'imposition mondialisation cela serait
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est un texte en braille laïque thème
est acquis une vision concordataire du
rapport aux religions et qui créent une
suspicion sur des fautes m
vahid de de l'islam l'islamisme comme
vous dites ou le djihadisme ce combat
par des mesures de police et des mesures
de renseignement et pas par ce barnum
politique et vous avez dit l'argument
pendant d'être long et parce qu'ils
veulent faire une présidentielle là
dessus qui vise à dire les insoumis soit
en fait les amis du crime soit en fait
les amis des terroristes s'est arrêtée
c'est en flamand et dibi lisa c'est
honteux alors que c'est eux qui sont
responsables des problèmes que nous
avons et je reviens sur ce chrono
regardez ces lapins voyez je me
laisserai pas faire ça ce sujet si on
poursuit cette émission maintenant avec
le rapport explosif du sénat sur la
commission denquête qu'ovide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur
la corrida remis cette semaine un
rapport accablant pour le gouvernement
elle dénonce l'impréparation de l'état
elle vise plus particulièrement jérôme
salomon sur sa gestion des stocks de
masques sandra cerqueira
c'est un rapport qui met directement en
cause jérôme salomon la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur la gestion du coc
vide accuse le directeur général de la
santé d'être responsable du manque de
masque sans avoir averti agnès buzyn
bien qu'alerter en 2018 par santé
publique france que 600 millions de
masques sont déclarés non conformes
jérôme salomon décide de ne commander
que 50 millions de masques les sénateurs
reproche au gouvernement d'avoir
sciemment dissimulé ce fiasco
il avait en effet une parfaite
connaissance de la situation dramatique
est sa responsabilité en la matière par
exemple dès le 13 mars la direction
générale de santé dont a reçu donc avant
le confinement une note qui indiquait
noir sur blanc que la france était
confrontée à une pénurie d'équipements
de protection individuelle la commission
d' enquête dévoile aussi un échange de
mails entre jérôme salomon --l'agence
santé publique france attestant de
pressions directes sur l' agence pour
empêcher que ne soit rendu public un
rapport d expertise un rapport
recommandant de se doter d'un milliard
de masques et venant contredire la
décision du directeur général de la
santé de ne pas reconstituer ce fameux
stocks
jérôme salomon demande la modification
de ce rapport pourquoi parce que ce
rapport disait très clairement dans sa
première version
il faut un stock d'un milliard de
masques jérôme salomon est intervenu
pour le faire modifier et donc à
posteriori pour légitimer sa décision et
ça c'est un acte qui est grave
une pénurie de masques qui restera selon
les sénateurs le triste symbole de
l'état d'impréparation du pays face à la
crise sanitaire
il déplore que ce manque d'anticipation
et conduit à passer des commandes
massives et coûteuses sur un marché sous
tension
qu'est-ce que vous inspire alexis
corbière les conclusions de ce rapport
qui est vraiment accablant pour l'état
notamment sur la question de la gestion
des masques et puis aussi qui visent
directement le directeur général de la
santé jérôme salomon donc le jeu déjà je
lui tiens à féliciter des sénateurs
c'est bien parce qu'ils font des
rapports que l'assemblée on peut pas
fait
et des enquêtes nécessaires on l'a vu
sur d'autres sujets malgré tout les
désaccords que je peux avoir avec la
majorité du sénat mais franchement
heureusement qu'ils sont là c'est
accablant
c'était droite et gauche un nom mais
j'entends bien mais un vendeur c'est
accablant
si c'est vrai ce cas de danger pas de
raison de considérer comme des
dessinateurs sont des gens sérieux ce
serait mais c'est accablant je pense
qu'il faut qu'il démissionne évidemment
je pense que monsieur salomon sa
responsabilité est engagée
s'il ya quelqu'un quelque chose de l'api
grave ya aussi une responsabilité
politique
on a eu plein d'âme buzançais mise de la
santé secteur portuaire de mousse et
uniquement gérant de salon qui est aussi
le ministre qui avait au dessus fallu
dire madame busin est parti faire
campagne aux élections municipales le
rapport d'ailleurs le dit oui que
c'était quand même partie comme en mal
et n'avaient pas alerté à niort brisant
sarrio sur le nombre de masques et de 10
ans que le stock de masques vous
demander sa démission
je suis sur sa responsabilité sa
démission ne semble si tout ça est
établie en plus que vous avez dit il
aurait y compris caviardé si je puis
dire ou demander qu'un rapport soit
corrigé enfin c'est quand gras pour
évidemment j'ai fait le calcul on est
passés donc de 700 millions de masques à
700000 tout ça a coûté fort cher
d'ailleurs c'est ce que dira je cite le
rapport sénatorial quelque chose
finalement ça nous aura coûté 450
millions quelque chose qui aurait pu
coûter 27 millions si on avait achetés
les masques au bon moment gaspillage
d'argent public
notre santé collective mis en place là
on arrive à ce que à la désorganisation
qui est la conséquence aussi de la sq
ont subi on encore le parlement ne va
pas le commenter ce qu'on n'a plus le
temps mais ce qu'annoncé histoire que
monsieur castex permet je dire cette
gabegie qui est du soudan à des
politiques d'ailleurs de réduction de
dépenses attraction budgétaire via le
fait de ne pas reproduire ce qui avait
été considéré à l'époque comme l'erreur
politique de roselyne bachelot
ça c'est d'ailleurs été critiqué mais
aussi des politiques et la
responsabilité de madame touraine aussi
de marisol touraine est engagée je veux
dire cette conception qui vise à faire
des économies parce qu'il ya une
cohérence malgré tout il faut remise qui
sont succédé qui a un impact sur notre
hôpital réduction sur la santé ce que
vous dites bas me semblé gelé en train
de le vivre c'est à dire que ce qui est
en train de se passer
malgré tout la stratégie de confinement
d'un point de vue médical est la
conséquence de la difficulté
d'absorption que nous avons dans notre
hôpital public
j'espère que tout le monde a compris que
les politiques de réduction du service
public ça a des conséquences dans nos
quartiers on l'a vu sur le thème
précédent je reviens pas mais quand
l'école publique est affaibli est bien
il ya parfois des courants spirituels
partiront radicaux qui se développe sa
des conséquences dans notre santé parce
que quand nous sommes face à un virus et
nous on veut nous devrons faire face à
d'autres virus et bien l'hôpital public
notre système de santé est affaibli en
effet à la place du gouvernement mette
plus de moyens s'avança les années
précédentes vous connais pour ton
réinvestir là-dedans faire de tout ça
une priorité est évidemment vous savez
ce qu'est la matérialisation concrète
d'un principe républicain s'appelle le
service public hôpital école police et
tout ça était affaibli et tout cet
affaiblissement parce qu'il était de bon
ton finalement de dire aller à trop
d'état ça coûte trop cher nous coûtent
fort cher à l'heure actuelle ça nous
coûte fort cher si je puis dire vous
savez ce qu'ils considéraient que notre
programme coûter cher on voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences que ça le
libéralisme économique fou qui vise à
affaiblir la puissance publique a des
conséquences terribles et nous sommes en
train de les vivre ni vous ni moi on
aurait cru ça possible on ferme les
magasins là vous allez avoir une fronde
de commerçants qui va venir j'en suis
persuadé au mois de janvier
moi je les vois les gens les
restaurateurs les restaurateurs
commerçants 10 ans peuvent plus ils vont
fermer et eux c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas de tradition en plus souvent de
comment dirais-je de combat collectif
etc et qui sont en train maudit qui sont
dans une colère qui a une sorte de dieu
j'appelle pas ça le poujadisme aimé
parce que poujadisme il y avait un côté
comment dire un réactionnaire certains
sujets mais une révolte légitime d'un
certain point de vue de gens qu'ils sont
et sa voix sans que vous ne retenez plus
vos coups contre le gouvernement est ce
que ça ne risque pas aussi un peu dans
ce contexte de crise sanitaire
d'augmenter la défiance des français
alors qu'on est dans un moment où la
confiance sociale est nécessaire pour la
stratégie vaccinale pour aussi comme
créer une forme d'unité dans ce moment
de crise qu'on n'a jamais vécu vous
l'avez dit pour ce qui est de la france
with on n'a jamais joué je veux dire aux
imbéciles dans le sens où évidemment
qu'il faut faire attention
là on n'a pas mis le match tous les
trois mais sitôt constitution le mais on
fait attention il ya toute une série de
règles et d'un protocole sanitaire
évidemment ces personnes croient que et
j'invite les français à le faire à être
rigoureux même si je dire de ce point de
vue là mais on peut quand même
s'interroger tout en respectant tout ça
2 comment on en est arrivé là et comment
on ne reproduit pas les choses et je
jouais pas développé ce que je viens de
dire
il me semble quand même que c'est trop
facile de dire c'est la faute à pas de
chance il ya des politiques économiques
libérales qui ont été menées et qui ont
pour conséquence de nous mais est
reparti comme en difficulté aujourd'hui
est le rapport si interne nous montre
que le premier confinement a été fort
mal géré et s'il ya des conséquences sur
la deuxième vague qui nous arrive est la
troisième peut-être aller en termine
avec la réforme de la justice des
mineurs à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement révise l'ordonance
fondatrice de 45 sur l'enfance
délinquante objectif principal réduire
les délais de la justice pour les
mineurs avec une audience de culpabilité
maximum trois mois après les faits en
écoute elle garde des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti 45% des affaires sont
jugées après que le mineur a atteint ses
18 ans c'est pourquoi nous supprimons la
phase de mise en examen qui je le
rappelle est aujourd'hui encadrée par
aucun délai la nouvelle procédure dite
de césure permettent une intervention
judiciaire plus proche du passage à
l'acte dans un délai compris entre dix
jours et trois mois avec l'audience de
culpabilité cette première audience est
cruciale car elle permet de faire
respecter le droit fondamental d'un
mineur avoir statué sur sa culpabilité
dans un délai raisonnable alors
qu'aujourd'hui ce délai est de 18 mois
en moyenne
alexis corbière est-ce que vous
approuvez le principe de la césure qui
est compris dans ce texte qui permet
donc l'accélération des délais au moins
cette audience de culpabilité pour que
les jeunes est un un jugement plutôt
qu'aujourd'hui trois mois maximum ou les
dix mois sur tout ce que moi je lis
toujours mieux que les gens soient jugés
le plus rapidement possible mais
l'esprit de de cette loi c'est de
revenir sur leurs noces de 45 tel que
vous l'avez dit de ne plus considérer le
mineur comme quand formation mais de
considérer qu'il peut être sanctionnés
ils sont des agences la date de 45 tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fait qu'il
fallait quand même une réforme d'ampleur
de cette réforme mais a déjà eu 39
amendements sur cette heure mais là on
va toujours vers l'idée que finalement
cette spécificité du jeune est remis en
cause ce que je veux dire c'est que les
politiques de prévention la part de
mystère la suisse et les budgets sont à
la baisse et des politiques de
répression d'éléments de répression sont
plus importants voilà je ne suis pas un
doux
rêveur je sais bien comme on a
aujourd'hui des jeunes qui sont violents
et d'ores et déjà il ya des jeunes qui
sont mis en prison que personne ne croit
que contrairement à ce qui se dit la
justice est laxiste mais il faut aussi
des moyens de prévention moi je la vois
cette genèse la droite juge le texte
trop laxistes oui mais la droite vous
savez bien souvent ne pas faire de
prison avant 13 ans les grands fonds si
si si il ya plus de possibilités de
sanctions pour des jeunes notamment de
moins de 16 ans autour de 16 ans et
moins de politique de prévention
la mise en détention quand même et plus
et plus possible que ce qu'elles étaient
avant et je dis attention à ce que cette
pente qui consisterait sion a considéré
que nous n'avons pas affaire un jeune en
formation avec tout les défauts que ça
peut avoir mais un quasi adultes moi je
pense qu'un mineur n'a pas sa place en
prison en vérité est là encore je le dis
sans l'encore naïveté parce que je suis
un élu de quartier où on a des jeunes
violents mais j'observe aussi que selon
cette violence elle va de pair avec ce
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure on
sait la même discussion tout à l'heure
la fermeture de services publics il ya
plus d'associations de terrain etc
donc attention à ce que nous ne
fabriquons pas par des choix économiques
une société violente
le budget de la justice est vraiment en
hausse 1 pour lui pourrait non mais il
était quasiment en situation de scandale
à je veux dire nous on a une absence de
magistrats j'ai tout à fait les chiffres
en tête mais tribunal de bobigny est une
situation absolument dramatique est ce
que vous savez exemple tout bête si vous
êtes une femme voulait divorcer ça pense
que je ne souhaite à personne et je
souhaite ne pas de se marrer d'ailleurs
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais ces
quelques mois en à paris et ses plus de
18 mois à bobigny enfin je veux dire la
justice en seine saint denis elle est
dans un état d'atonie et en particulier
vis-à-vis des de cette jeunesse qui qui
qui qui qui qui pose mais qui pose
problème donc lui donner quelques mois
supplémentaires ou si on peut avancer
des chiffres ça reste quand même une
situation de grande tension ciel et que
c'est qu'un verre d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci tu as merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
bien évidemment la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]